what's up y'all my name is benjamin
abiola and i am a first generation
british born nigerian and today we are
going to be talking about code switching
i define code switching as basically the
way one person alternates their language
their speech their dialect depending on
the situation and the people that you're
around this was just a survival tactic
for me growing up so i didn't even know
there was an official oxford webster
dictionary definition of code switching
i'm going to be talking about how i code
switch in my life personally because i
co-switch every day this is the code i
use when i'm talking to my friends
bruh can you believe the fight that
happened today at school brad's what i'm
saying he jumped over the table picked
up the tray blink minked on his head
it's like yo this was crazy hold on one
second my mom's calling hello hello
mommy yes no i'm just hanging out with
my friends no no we're just talking
about bible study and everything that
we're going to do
yes and here's the thing about african
parents when they get on the phone with
you they're going to make sure they give
you a prayer before they get off the
phone
amen the lord will bless you too
okay uh i'll talk to you later okay
bye-bye
man what y'all laughing at man i used to
feel some type of way i was like let me
go off to the corner and take this phone
call and not be in front of everybody
but to the point where it was like you
know what i don't care this is the truth
this is my troop and now we are in
london england where i was born where my
sister still lives and this is where i
switch back to this coke because i feel
a lot more comfortable speaking to her
with a british accent than i do in my
american accent she's also very
apprehensive of it because she feels
like i'm an americanized person now and
i think that's just me wanting to stick
to that code and still feel that sense
of belonging to how i grew up let's give
my sister a call how about that yo
so i was thinking this morning i was
like yeah i haven't talked to my sister
in a minute so i might as well call her
yeah how you feel
i'm so great
what are you laughing for like what's
the problem
and here's the thing about my sister
anytime i talk to her she always laughs
or she always points out the fact like
why am i still speaking with this
british coat but the thing is i'm still
that your american accent is terrible
though no yeah all right let me hear it
like i'm about to like meet up with one
of my friends
howdy y'all and now we're in texas when
i moved from england to texas it was a
big adjustment i would be in class and
i'd be answering the questions just
trying to be a good student yeah i might
have the answer to that
um well here's the thing on page four
what's what's so funny and i had my
friends like oi harry potter oy get us
some tea and biscuits well harry potter
is actually a fictional character it's
not real i'm not not the real no i'm not
the black harry potter i do hello hamora
spelliamos
it's me winding curses on all of my
friends who made fun of me in the 7th
grade
can y'all get some wizardry
[Music]
i had to deal with that every day so i
started picking up the language of my
friends that i did make and calling
everything a hoe from going from harry
potter to hey ho what's up if you meet a
person from texas and they call you a
hoe they're just giving you an overall
encompassing definition of something
that they may not feel like they should
define so if i say yo could you pass me
that hole and i'm talking about my water
cup just pass me my cup of water please
and now we switch to the corporate code
this is my professional sitting for
professional settings a lot of people
like to refer it as speaking properly or
talking white i can talk to you like you
crazy and i can also talk to you like
you have some sense when you switch to
this code you're in this code for a
specific reason and that is to solve the
problem
hi this is johnson what brings you in
today absolutely yeah let me just pull
up your account real quick oh i see yeah
um well you have 200 in overdraft fees i
i do not actually set the prices no you
would like my manager's actually out at
the moment i can just handle this for
you right here right now no need to yell
no need to yell i understand yes ms
johnson this is a one-time courtesy
refund uh-huh thank you ms johnson
okay
all right okay goodbye
ladies and gentlemen that's how you
switch in the corporate world and it
saves you from cussing out code
switching in the workplace is an
everyday occurrence but sometimes
there's those co-workers that you feel
way more comfortable talking to than
others for example my black co-workers
bruh did you see the reports michelle
left on my desk literally racks on racks
on racks just how do you expect me to
have this done by the end of the day
straight tripping hey what's up john
yeah i know i'm actually super swamped
right now michelle just left a whole
bunch of paperwork on my desk hiling up
literally yeah i don't know it's kind of
out of line now can you imagine if i
would have said she was straight
tripping the john he probably would have
went and told my manager and i probably
would have got fired so sometimes cold
switching saves you a job but a lot of
times it actually gets real and it's not
all peaches and berries i walked into
work and there was an all lives matter
sign waiting for me greeting me saying
hello black man tell me how you feel
about this and boy was i livid i logged
into our emails and i saw that someone
else had put all our lives matter back
the blue as a signature that got sent
out to everybody in the workplace my
question is well damn if i would have
did this that probably would have been a
problem so i go into the office i talk
to my black friend bruh
do you see the
the disrespect
john black lives matter because black
people are getting killed by the police
at an alarming rate it's actually
disproportionate to other races bruh how
does he not get that that's what i'm
saying you didn't see him out there
marching for michael brown you didn't
see him say black lives matter in any of
the emails they didn't even come to us
to ask if we was okay john the reason
i'm upset is because no one here has
ever said anything to appease the
situation where's the empathy all you
all do is say all lives matter as if
it's a pacifier to stop us from saying
black lives matter but here's the thing
if all lives truly matter then black
lives would too you get where i'm coming
from how does he not get that bruh i'm
about done in this job man straight up
so cold switching saved me a job and
saved somebody getting their ass what
now if you made it this far into the
video you're probably wondering who the
hell is ben really is he nigerian is he
british is he harry potter is he a hoe
is he a professional is he a corporate
american working banker who is he and
what does he do
the answer is i'm all of these things
that's right one code doesn't define
anybody and in my personal experience
all of these codes have helped me be who
i am today i got a dm from a friend and
she was like you lie so good i don't
even know who you are i just told her
that i have different things in my life
that allow me to identify with different
moments you are being true to yourself
because that's something that you're
doing to help other people either feel
more comfortable or adapting to a
specific situation but here's a code
twitch psa for all of my lovely
caucasians out there if you have a black
friend who you deem as well spoken or
not like the others or oh you're just
you're just so different well he's
probably or she's probably just code
switching to make you feel comfortable
so again mind your words and switch them
up
[Music]
you